make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and in
this video i want to make you guys an
expert
on the power broker in marvel comics in
30 minutes or less
now here's the thing i was gonna do a
video on wilford nagle uh but
his whole arc is confined to like
basically four
issues right i mean that's really all
you get over the course of the original
isaiah bradley story
uh you know truth red white and black so
we're already covering that story so
there's not really any need because i
feel like it would be redundant to do
wilfred nigel explain so we're going to
do that on geek culture explain right
we'll do that as like you know a 10
minute video or something like that
because we don't do 10 minute
explanation videos here we do long form
stuff
so uh here's the thing about power
broker it's a misconception that he
appeared in captain america number 230
it's actually not true well
it is true but it's not true right the
the long and short of this is that
the the character of power broker
originally appeared in the old machine
man
stories by jack kirby but he didn't have
a name he was given the name curtis
jackson and captain america 230 by roger
mckenzie and roger stern and then he got
the name power broker and the thing
volume 1 issue number 33 by michael
kalyn it's one of these things where it
just took marvel a while to get around
to giving this guy an
actual identity but there's a reason for
that uh the old jack kirby stories were
pretty straightforward that's one of the
great things about jack kirby
storytelling is
yes there were some deep plot threads
and they would kind of span on for a
little while and he wrote some pretty
complex stuff but in terms of the
the level of depth that you needed to
understand what was going on in the
story they were never too difficult
right and so in the old machine man
volume one series starting with issue
number seven you had a friend of machine
man aaron stack a guy by the name of
peter spalding and peter spaulding was
basically kidnapped by what was called
the corporation
this kind of criminal enterprise that
existed out there uh and that with aaron
stack being the most advanced machine on
the world at the time
uh that the idea of the corporation was
to essentially use the
the design of machine man to create more
of him right to create their own
personal robot army essentially and so
they ended up kidnapping peter spalding
and then they left machine man
instructions he followed them he showed
up at their base of operations
and then ultimately freed himself and
freed peter and then that was basically
it right the story was pretty
straightforward uh but from there you go
into when power broker effectively
starts to matter
and that's the next year right the old
machine man story was in 1978
in 1979 you got captain america 230. and
the reality was that at the time
with marvel reintroducing captain
america in avengers issue number four
the truth about this i mean if we're
being honest with ourselves the truth
about this is
no one knew what to do with it but it
wasn't until you got to the mark
grunwald run with issue number 307
running all the way to 443 that suddenly
marvel had a direction for the character
but he was just there and that's one of
the reasons why when you talk to people
who read captain america back during
like the the 70s leading up to
uh mark greenwald's run that they see
him as more of an avengers character as
opposed to like his own standalone
superhero because most all the stories
that he had that mattered up to that
point was when he was part of the
avengers team
right his own solo series just was kind
of there and stuff happened and he
existed and
that's essentially it and so the way
this played out is that with
a little bit of lead up that actually
happened in captain america 222 that sam
wilson had essentially just vanished
right he just disappeared
and the belief at the time by nick fury
was that he had abandoned his post
and so what you had was him going to
captain america in 230 and saying we
need you to find sam wilson we have no
idea where he went to
now along for the ride at the time were
a few different things the first was a
guy named the miracle man
and the second are what were called the
super shield agents now the miracle man
was a guy named wendell vaughn most of
you guys have heard of him and you know
him as
quasar that's probably the most positive
the most popular role that he's had in
marvel by the time he was newly
introduced
and the super shield agents were guys
like blue streak and vamp they were
basically individuals who were super
powered right who had abilities and they
would offer as kind of like a step up
from your average shield agent and so
captain america ended up grabbing
miracle man along with the super shield
agents and then went to go track dance
uh track down sam wilson
ultimately locating him in a base of
operations uh you know under alcatraz
which of course was being ran by
curtis jackson and that's when curtis
jackson is first named in marvel comics
he basically says like i'm here i'm
curtis jackson that kind of a thing but
the reality and the the whole plot of
this story centered around the notion
that uh curtis jackson had essentially
had his guys
uh which were basically vamp and blue
streak right they actually turned out to
end up you know being agents for the
corporation uh the curtis jackson ran
the west coast division of this
multinational
uh criminal enterprise and that he had
kidnapped sam wilson for the purpose of
drawing captain america
in order to have captain america go and
grab the nephew of sam wilson a guy
named
jim wilson and the reason why is because
curtis jackson and his guys had already
kidnapped bruce banner and the reason
for this was because they wanted to use
the incredible hulk
jim wilson the nephew of sam wilson and
marvel comics at the time
was a friend of the incredible hulk and
so it was believed they could use jim
wilson to manipulate the hulk into doing
their bidding of course
everything opposite of that happened
there was a little bit of corporate
espionage that took place
in the sense that the head of the east
coast operations of the corporation a
guy by the name of kliger had actually
captured jim
jim wilson already and so it was one of
these things where they were kind of
vying for power and trying to position
themselves clicker was trying to take
over like all the operations for the
corporation
across the united states and uh it
basically made curtis jackson look bad
in the sense that clicker could do
something that he couldn't do
uh and of course you know once bruce
banner wakes up and he realizes what's
going on the incredible hulk freaks
out and starts trashing everything and
the day is basically safe but it was an
instance where marvel was able to have
wendell vaughn as miracle man
face off against the incredible hulk to
give us his fans a display of what his
power was and it actually proved to be
hugely successful following that like he
just went on to become quasar and became
a mainstay comic character after that
right which all kind of ran into the
dan avenue era in the mid 2000s with
annihilation when he consolidated all
the space faring stuff into one great
big huge epic tale but following the
story there was a little bit of
involvement with curtis jackson
by roger stern in the old incredible
hulk story starting with issue number
235 uh running all the way up to the
issue of 237
um it was a pretty straightforward issue
right i mean or pretty straightforward
story right spanning like two or three
parts uh it just kind of
led to curtis jackson trying to
manipulate the hulk again and then
ultimately fighting machine man and
there wasn't a whole lot going on there
the important thing that happened with
curtis jackson and the notion or the
concept of the power broker enterprise
actually started in captain america 328
running all the way up to 331 and all
that really happened here it was kind of
a series of of smaller little events
that were taking place
you had a guy by the name of d-man who
was kind of like this wolverine s
character he's a bit of a joke
in marvel comics but he popped up on the
scene and the idea that like john walker
and battlestar had like strength and
speed enhancements had just kind of come
out of nowhere
and so this was sort of building up as
far as mark grunwald was concerned
this idea that like somebody out there
was giving these people powers and
nobody really knew who it was it wasn't
until you got to captain america 364 by
mark gruenwald that you basically found
out that curtis jackson had founded
something called power broker
incorporated which was basically a
subsidiary of the corporation that
curtis jackson inherently worked for
and was basically just a way to broker
powers the way he did this was with a
guy named
carl malus and carl malus was the one
who was being featured in those
those older captain america 328-331
comics who was basically kidnapping
people and then like taking a sample of
their powers and then using that to
basically store them so that they could
be used by power broker incorporated
because carl malus was a guy who was
obsessed with powers and using those
powers manipulating those powers giving
powers to other people things like that
his actions over the course of his life
had drawn the attention of curtis who
would hire him on is essentially the
scientific arm of power broker
incorporated and the guy that could
actually
make the company work and so because of
that with captain america 364
bringing in the idea of curtis jackson
being the power broker this ran directly
into what was in effect uh the thing
volume one
by michael kalin and the reality of this
is that the thing was kind of like the
powerhouse of
the fantastic four and the popularity of
his character cannot really be
overstated here
fans loved the thing they loved ben
grimm the fantastic four up to that
point was basically the first family of
marvel and while their stories would
drop
off rapidly in the 1990s when you had
guys like john byrne who were writing
and drawing the fantastic four stories
back then they were amazing right they
were exceedingly well done uh and so
that kind of popularity and
the complexity the the dynamic of a
family superhero team
bickering and squabbling with one
another which was started with stan lee
and jack kirby just kind of continued on
as a mainstay right so even 20 years
after their introduction
they were still super popular and so
with the thing being so popular marvel
saw fit to give him a solo series try to
just kind of experiment and see what
would happen
it wasn't really my cup of tea i wasn't
really a big fan of the thing solo
series but a lot of people liked it but
it made sense that if the thing was a
super strong guy
then have him face off against the power
broker and so in the thing vol 1 issue
number 33
and really going into 35 we find out
that the power broker and his ability to
give people super strength
is the reason why 75 of the wrestlers in
the unlimited wrestling federation
and mobile comics got their powers from
the power broker we also ended up
learning here that
it was one thing to give people
abilities as a one-off
right but the issue is that if the
corporation you know first and foremost
was a criminal enterprise
wanting to make money and the power
broker incorporated was designed to be
the legitimate business face of the
corporation itself then how would you
keep people coming back right because
after a while you're going to run
through everybody who wants powers or
you're going to draw too much heat on
yourself
and uh authorities are going to come
cracking down and so what they did
what what carl malus and curtis jackson
did is they created a substance or a
chemical
that was highly addictive and then added
it to the power implementation process
so that when those individuals came to
the power broker to to gain abilities
they would essentially become addicted
and they would constantly have to go
back
and constantly pay huge sums of money in
order to either keep their powers
or to ensure their power stayed afloat
the lie that was told
was that once they received the serum
enhancement that they would basically
have to keep coming back for regular
treatments in order to ensure they kept
their powers
and by using this addictive substance
their statement was at least as far as
the people who had those powers was
concerned
backed up right it was a truthful thing
they just didn't truly know what was
going on
uh and so with the thing solo series by
michael kalin all you really saw here
was a few things happening right you saw
power broker incorporated creating what
were called the grapplers which was
basically like their own
super villain team that was composed of
just some pretty strong heavy hitters uh
you saw the thing or at least you saw
the idea of the grapplers being built up
to
by the thing facing off against
different members of the grapplers over
time so it was kind of like facing off
against one guy and then another guy
then another guy
and then at the end of it all fighting
them all at the same time right so
that's kind of
the slow build that you basically got
there but following that
and and kind of uh an accompanying story
or really even
you know more of a flashback or a series
of preludes uh with captain america vol
1 issues number 331 uh running all the
way up to the actual annual for issue
number 12. uh what you basically saw
here
was mark gruenwald and company
essentially wrapping up the whole power
broker story arc right and the way this
worked
is you ended up having the introduction
of a character called the scourge or a
scourge of the underworld we don't
really know much about this guy he was
more of like a punisher-esque
type character but the way this played
out is that scourge was basically on the
hunt for
curtis jackson right trying to take this
guy out and so what you ended up having
was him alongside uh i guess in the
sister or the the person he was with
um you know lyons who essentially took
refuge from scourge
who ultimately cornered curtis jackson
and so in a last-ditch act of
desperation
curtis actually subjected himself to his
own uh superhero
enhancement process the problem with
this was that when it was established
in and really with captain america 335
and even going into 364 and as part of
the thing story arc the one of the big
side effects is you didn't know exactly
what was going to happen
that some individuals actually died when
they underwent the process others
went through it fine and so there was no
indication of what would happen here and
even curtis himself kind of stated there
was a 50 50 chance he would survive if
he underwent the process
and a 100 chance he would die if a
scourge of the underworld gets in that
room and goes after him and jennifer
lyons and so
uh when he underwent the process what
ended up happening is his body actually
grew to this massive
muscle clad size to the point that he
couldn't really even move right he was
literally just
too big to be able to control his own
body and he remained that way for
essentially the rest of the story arc uh
going all the way into annual number 12.
you did have carl malus who actually
went through and tried to de-augment
various individuals and the results were
pretty grotesque some of the guys were
really screwed up in terms of how they
looked but the reality of this is that
he just kind of stayed that way and by
all standards
of measurement from mark gruenwald and
them there was no intention of bringing
him back right there was no it was it
was kind of like he's gone now right
he's just out of the picture done and
that's basically it
all that changed with essentially
maximum security in 2000 in the sense
that where this guy was supposed to have
been gone marvel just kind of wrote in
that somewhere along the line he was
essentially de-augmented right he went
back to his normal self now maximum
security was basically a story arc where
the cree turned the earth into a prison
planet and ron and the accuser was the
the warden for it all it's it sounds
cool i promise you it's not it's not a
good story
it really really sucks uh and as far as
curtis's involvement here it was really
just trying to use like alien technology
to mind control us agent
different things like that it was not
really all that great um there was a
little bit that went on there
more recently back in 2011 with captain
america 615
and kind of the tie-in issues for that
marvel tried to bring him back
but the reality of this is that curtis
jackson was reminiscent of a bygone h
right there was no real interest
in his character there wasn't real
really any interest in a guy who could
broker powers to individuals and a lot
of that kind of came out of the fact
that that
as far as people perceived marvel at the
time because of the work that had been
put in by joe casada jimmy palmiotti
right the work they'd done
at event publications when joe casada
became editor-in-chief all those things
that had gone on marvel was just
condensing down
right they were literally just getting
rid of everything that's why you got
house of m
when you saw the you know 98 percent of
mutants lose their powers at the hands
of the scarlet witch when peter parker's
marriage to mary jane watson was
nullified uh when the avengers were
disassembled i mean
it was it was judgment day in marvel
comics like asada went through and just
cleaned house
and so people's perception was okay if
marvel's gonna start reintroducing
things then it's gotta be things that
matter and things that are important uh
and curtis jackson just wasn't one of
those right he's just not what he just
wasn't something that fans were really
interested in
and so you saw a little bit of a story
arc and you saw a little bit of
involvement here but that was it right
you go into
uh the punisher vol 9 with issue number
13 and there is a
marvel really kind of throws it out
there that like or at least the the
prevailing theory among fans
is that curtis was killed by the
punisher there really isn't anything to
support that uh as far as i'm aware he
just
his kind of he was just there right and
that was it right we don't really know
what happened to him we don't know
really where he went
um presumably he'll show back up in the
u.s agent storyline as it exists right
now
uh and because of what we're seeing in
falcon and winter soldier i can bet you
by the bottom dollar he will show up
somewhere
marvel marvel comics just kind of chases
after the movies now and releases
content based on what the movies are
doing
um so most likely you'll see him
reappear but that's basically it right i
mean power broker is pretty basic pretty
straightforward um he was a guy who at
one point rose to prominence as a member
of what was called the corporation
a criminal enterprise he essentially
gave people powers and then just kind of
drifted off to the land of obscurity
when marvel stopped caring and fans
thought caring so with that being said
guys we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to comments
explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
we all come from somewhere
a place with a name
we can make it happen
[Music]
turn things around
let's be the change we want to see
[Music]
[Music]
is